all right many beaches are shut down
this holiday weekend as new cases
increase in nearly 40 states that
includes Galveston Texas where this year
officials hope people will stay home to
stay safe Janet shamlian has our report
the fourth of July weekend for most of
the country won't be a day at the beach
it is what it is I guess we got to be
safe
the Rochas have been planning this trip
to Galveston since January we're trying
to make the best of it it's a little
disappointing from coast to coast
beach towns are scrambling to stop
scenes like these from Memorial Day
weekend when people packed pools water
parks and beaches many without masks but
Galveston on the Texas Gulf Coast has
more cases per capita than Dallas or
Austin we're seeing a surge in young
people who are really just not paying
any regard to the risk of this
California's Newport Beach closed after
two lifeguards tested positive for kovat
19 now nearly two dozen other lifeguards
are in quarantine it's difficult for us
throughout this time the beach is kind
of where I've gone to to make myself
feel better Florida is drawing a line in
the sand
many Atlantic coast beaches are closed
but along the state's Panhandle Panama
Beach is open even almost doubling the
number of lifeguards on duty to the
north in New York City all 14 miles of
Beach reopened this week we're heading
in the right direction right now it
ain't over yet but back in Galveston the
owner of this popular beachside spot
worries where tourists will go there's
gonna be an inability for them to enjoy
themselves on the beach and that's going
to lead to an inability for them a
socially distance themselves and it
could be more of a hindrance than a
solution
Galveston Island in so many beach towns
rely on this holiday weekend for their
livelihood but this year health is the
priority and as you can see as of this
morning the signs are up the beach is
closed but will this gamble pay off
closing the beaches on a steamy July
weekend officials say it will be several
weeks before they know whether cases
drop gale no Janet Bob Spadaro chilling
in his beach chair had it best it ain't
over yet we need to remember that thank
you very much